قال تقرير للبنك الاوروبي للاعمار
والتنميه ان نسبه النمو تراجعت في مصر الى
4.1% مؤكدا ان الطريق الى خفض التضخم شاقه
وطويله في اشاره الى مخاطر اقتصاديه
متفاقمه وشكوك في قدره القاهره على السداد
ديونها فان كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حقيقه الوضع المالي
والاقتصادي في مصر على ضوء تقييمات
الاخيره اي افق ينتظر الجوله الجديده من
المفاوضات بين الحكومه المصريه وصندوق
النقد الدولي وما واجهه الربط بين تفكير
موعد الانتخابات والوضع الاقتصادي الذي
تعيشه البلاد
[موسيقى]
المصري يعاني معاناه شديده جدا نتيجه غياب
مفهوم التنميه الشامله امام غياب مفهوم
للاولويه عدم الادراك لان دعم الصادرات
ودعم الصناعات الصغيره ومكافحه الفقر
والانفاق على
الزراعه والصناعه وعلى الاقتصاد الحقيقي
اهم بكثير جدا من المشروعات العملاقه
وخطوط النقل الفائقه السرعه المصري بتعاني
من ارتفاع معدلات التضخم لكن ليست مصر
وحدها يعني واضح ان حتى اوروبا التي لم
يتخطى فيها التضخم لسنوات طويله حاجز
الرقمين نتاع خطى خلال هذه الفتره حاجز
الرقمين لكن هناك مؤشرات جيده ايضا في
الاقتصاد المصري هو على الاقل هناك تراجع
في ميزان في ميزان في عجز الميزان التجاري
هناك تراجع في عجز ميزان المدفوعات مصر ما
زالت حتى هذه اللحظه بتمتلك احتياطي
ضخم من العملات
العملات النقديه الاجنبيه بيغطي ضعف
الفتره القانونيه المطلوبه يعني يغطي اكثر
من ست
الميزان التجاري قد قل نعم قد قل لان لا
توجد عمله اجنبيه فهناك تم انقاص بشكل
دراماتيكي حجم الواردات المصريه وهل بعد
هذه الوالدين تدخل كمواد اوليه في
الصادرات المصريه وهذا امر مضر جدا النقدي
في مصر الان 34 مليار دولار تقريبا اكثر
من 28 مليار دولار يعني اكثر من 80% من
هذا الاحتياط النقدي ودائعه خارجيه لو
قررت فيه الدول الخليجيه سحب هذه الودائع
سينكشف الاقتصاد المصري ولا يتبقى
لاستيراد السلع الاساسيه في مصر اكثر من
شهرين نحن
امام سيطره تامه على الاقتصاد من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
نحن يعني امام امنيه ان يعني تستمع
القياده السياسيه في مصر الى ما ينبغي ان
يكون والى يعني اقوال الخبراء سواء من
صندوق النقد الدولي او البنك الدولي او
الاقتصادي كل الاقتصاديين في العالم
اجمعوا ان العسكريه ينبغي ان تبخر تماما
بالاقتصاد وحده يعني موازنه موحده موحده
للحكومه المصريه لجمهوريه مصر العربيه
ينبغي ان تكون هناك شفافيه وارقام معلنه
الان وبعد الدراسات يعني اوضحت الامور ان
المصريين قد لا يتحملون موجه جديده من من
التعويم يعني او مرونه بسعر صرف خاصه وان
سعر صرف الدولار وصل الى مستويات قياسيه
لم يصل اليها من قبل يجب ان يكون كل
الموازنات امام اعين البرلمان وان تكون
تحت سلطه الرقابه وان يكون هناك شفافيه
كامله في عرض الارقام هذا امر لا خلافه
عليه المشكله الحاليه الحاليه انه من اجل
ان يحدث ذلك يجب ان يكون هنالك اعاده
هيكله لهذه المؤسسات ولا هذه الشركات الان
الحلول بسيطه للغايه حينما تخرج الاخوه
المصريه باعتبار حقيقي ووجود اراده سياسيه
حقيقيه باننا لدينا موازنه موحده
الموازنه العامه للدوله بان هناك شفافيه
ورقابه حقيقيه طرح هذه المشروعات الجديده
من العاصمه الجديده والعالمين وكل هذه
المشروعات الغير مجديه الاقتصاديا للبيع
ومحاوله تقليل وتقليص الانفاق الحكومي
الضار الذي انفق على ما لا يوجد طائل من
ورائف
[موسيقى]
بدات الحكومه المصريه تستشعر ان الجزء او
التعاقدات التي تعهدت بها الى صندوق النقد
الدولي قد لا تتمكن من تنفيذها بالشكل
المطلوب بدا هناك نوع من انواع المفاوضات
او اطاله امام مدن المفاوضات على امل
تدبير جزء من العملات الصعبه تفكير
الانتخابات الرئاسيه جعل مصر في موقف
قانون يسمح لها بطلب ارجاء المفاوضات مع
اول مراجعات الى ما بعد انتهاء
الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه مصر يعني اعتقد ان
امامها على الاقل ثلاثه اشهر من اجل
التقاط الانفاس واعاده ترتيب البيت من
الداخل نحن يعني في انتظار قرارات ستكون
شديده الوطء على المصريين الذين انتقلوا
الكثير اكثر من ثلثينهم الان يعانون العيش